[Applauso]
t-shirt che oggi indosso è stata
prodotta in manga adesso
non so esattamente dove perché Perché in
etichetta non è scritto
per quanto riguarda le scarpe invece
sono state prodotte in provincia di
Salerno
per essere precisi le ultime fasi della
produzione sono state fatte a Salerno
mentre altre le fasi un po' più Creative
sono state fatte da Giuseppe nella sua
Bottega Artigiana
alcuni dei componenti arrivano da
un'azienda Toscana che utilizza energie
da fonti rinnovabili mentre le materie
prime arrivano da un allevamento
norvegese che applica pratiche di
agricoltura rigenerativa
queste sono solo alcune delle
informazioni che a breve troveremo su
tutti i capi che Indossiamo
mai prima nella storia
l'intera industria della moda si sta
scontrando con un concetto che è ormai
su tutti i tavoli di discussione
trasparenza parliamo di trasparenza
sono mai vent'anni che mi occupo di
quella che è la filiera produttiva del
mondo della moda a Italia Spagna
Germania ma anche Cina India Indonesia
Vietnam Cambogia Pakistan e Bangladesh
questo mi ha portato più di 200 volte in
Asia e in qualche modo plasmato un po'
quello che è il mio rapporto con questa
parola con la parola trasparenza
ricordo ancora la prima volta in cui
sono stato in Cina
era il 2002 avevo 25 anni Allora fu un
viaggio brevissimo quattro giorni il
venerdì di volo per andare in Cina
sabato e domenica per lavorare la
domenica sarà quello di rientro
fu molto breve ma mi ricordo
Praticamente tutto le ore di volo senza
riuscire a dormire gli scali l'aeroporto
di Hong Kong gli odori di Hong Kong il
traghetto il controllo passaporto e il
banco Ci aspettava per andare
direttamente al primo incontro
e lì incontrai David
devi dare un taiwanese era spaccia in
cantina era gentilissimo era il
fondatore ma anche il direttore generale
di un'azienda di 20.000 persone 20.000
persone che vivevano in questa città in
miniatura e
una città che aveva parking che aveva
biblioteca che aveva dormitori Ma che
aveva anche le guardie Armate in entrata
e l'incontro con David fu molto diverso
da tutti gli altri incontri che avevo
avuto fino a allora perché
la mia esperienza lavorativa sarà
costruita su un assunto base che i
clienti vogliono principalmente un buon
prodotto un buon servizio un buon prezzo
tutto il resto fa
segreti industriali e proprietà
intellettuale Alla fine meno ne sanno
meglio è E se ci pensiamo un po' tutta
l'industria italiana fatta sulle piccole
medie imprese sul saper fare sulla
sediatezza le saper fare si è cresciuta
su questa su questa base e l'industria
della moda ma tante altre
tendono a mantenere al loro interno
questo tipo di segretezza Beh con
l'incontro con dervi di realtà successe
qualcosa fin da subito Lui faceva molte
domande personali poche domande sul
prodotto quasi o dei Setta scontato
faceva molte domande su di me molte
domande sull'azienda con cui collaboravo
molte domande sulle persone che lavorano
in quella azienda
e capiva in qualche modo che mi sentivo
mi sentivo a disagio che non era mio
posto dall'altra parte è un ragazzo di
25 anni per la prima volta in Cina con
un inglese improbabile senza esperienza
e che si presenta in un incontro di
un'azienda del genere con la fidanzata a
fianco
Beh
qualcosa quello che è successo in quel
momento fu che
tutte le domande che faceva David
avevano una missione precisa lui voleva
capire se riusciva a instaurare un
rapporto di fiducia con la persona che
aveva davanti un rapporto di fiducia che
fosse basato su un rapporto di
trasparenza in base alle risposte che
gli davo lui stava decidendo se si
poteva affidare di me
questo fu un po' per i decenni
successivi la base su cui creai un po'
tutto il mio approccio al modello di
business
fino al 2012 dieci anni dopo
un'altra volta Hong Kong un viaggio di
rientro allora avevo 35 anni era a
novembre e
passai in un centro commerciale davanti
a un negozio
un negozio che avevo visto qualche
giorno prima sulle news era un negozio
che avevo notato perché viene mio si
parlava di movimento
che
si era tenuto nello stesso momento
davanti a 60 negozi in 20 Paesi nel
mondo contemporaneamente
mi ricordavo questi numeri in 60 negozi
20 paesi e infatti quell'inverno
Greenpeace lanciò per la prima volta la
campagna detox My fashion che
voleva portare l'attenzione dell'impatto
dell'Industria della moda sugli ambienti
negli ambiti sociali qualche degli
ambiti ambientali Anzi qualche anno dopo
Fashion Revolution fece la stessa
identica cosa Invece per quanto riguarda
la parte sociale
quel momento
come 10 anni prima fu significativo
tanto quanto l'incontro con David
quello che successe fu che lentamente
cambia praticamente tutto
cambia tutto perché se fino a quel
momento quello che contava era il
prodotto il prezzo il servizio Le
redazioni a un certo punto non bastava
più
il tipo di rapporto di relazione di
fiducia basato su fiducia fra persone ci
sta muovendo ad un livello diverso il
prodotto rimaneva Sì ancora centrale Ma
si dà la pace per scontato la fiducia fa
persone non era più sufficiente perché
si stava spostando in una fiducia sulle
aziende veniva richiesto che ci si
potesse fidare delle aziende
e la domanda che
tutti ci facevamo in quel momento ci
Sembrava molto semplice come tipologia
di problema da risolvere veniva
richiesto alle aziende che fossero che
sapessero dove producevano i loro
prodotti che sapessero con chi
collaboravano come le aziende con cui
collaboravano operassero nel settore
però ci si rese conto velocemente che in
realtà tanto semplice non era e non era
per un motivo molto molto chiaro perché
l'intera industria specialmente quella
della moda non è costruita per essere
trasparente Anzi è costruita per
mantenere tutta una serie di segreti al
suo interno proprio per non divulgare
per non divulgare informazioni della
propria fiera
ma in quel momento veniva richiesto
iniziava essere chiesto alle aziende di
mostrare che ci si poteva fidare che ci
si poteva affidare dell'azienda stessa
al di fuori delle persone e come si fa a
fidarsi di un'azienda Come si fa a
pretendere di utilizzare una parola così
legata rapporti fra persone come la
fiducia per traslando per un qualche
motivo sulle aziende o ancora peggio sui
Brand
e in realtà a un certo punto capire
c'era un lavoro di base non possiamo
pensare di fidarci di un'azienda noi
tendenzialmente pensiamo ci diciamo che
le aziende sono fatte di persone e
quindi
tendiamo a pensare che le aziende si
muovano come persone ma questo nella
maggior parte dei casi non succede
quello che dovremmo iniziare a fare è
pretendere qualcosa in meno non tanto
cerchiamo un rapporto di fiducia con le
aziende ma pretendere un qualcosa
che ancora una volta va
nell'area della trasparenza
la fiducia una sorta di trasparenza che
va oltre il concetto di fiducia Una
trasparenza che prima di tutto punta
a comprendere quello che succede
all'interno di un'azienda comprendere le
interazioni che l'azienda ha con altre
aziende come Queste si comportano Quali
sono le sfide che devono affrontare
parliamo di sfida ambientali sfide
sociali del mercato dell'Innovazione e
delle implicazioni etiche di tutto
questo
è una sfida che se
vinceremo porterà l'industria della moda
per intero business a diventare il
motore di un impatto positivo senza
precedenti la trasparenza può diventare
un asset per le aziende può diventare
valore di scambio può diventare un vero
e proprio valore patrimoniale per le
aziende
e quando di solito devo queste cose
Tendenzialmente c'è sempre un'obiezione
che mi viene posta che si sono tante
belle parole però poi nella realtà cosa
succede
Beh nella realtà Per quanto mi riguarda
questo estremamente molto concreto negli
ultimi 10 anni Da quando ho
approcciato il concetto della
trasparenza portandolo all'interno di
tutte le attività aziendali
proprio grazie alla trasparenza abbiamo
iniziato a collaborare con più di 50 a
prendere globali in 20 Paesi nel mondo e
con più di 2000 aziende avendo un
impatto delle aziende grazie al
trasparenza una delle aziende che ha
fondato è diventata una Bicocca grazie
alla trasparenza e al nostro modello di
business
stiamo cercando di
far diventare il nostro business un
catalizzatore di creazione di valore
sia economico ma anche sociale
ambientale e si può fare noi lo stiamo
facendo e Quando questo succede inizia
una cosa magica inizia una sorta di loop
un Loop in cui
vuoi cercare di fare sempre meglio prima
di tutto per te stesso per la tua
azienda Ma questo ha un implicazione è
un impatto su tutto su
business e sulle persone che lavorano in
quel business sui clienti che da un lato
Acquisiscono Maggiore consapevolezza Ma
dall'altro non devono necessariamente
più fidarsi possono vedere quello che va
e quello che non va È scegliere
è Una trasparenza che deve trascendere
il concetto di fiducia Siamo siamo
stanchi di vedere grandi proclami
specialmente quando si parla tanto oggi
di sostenibilità e senza mai avere dei
dati sottostanti che ci raccontano
quello che veramente sta succedendo
sarebbe più interessante forse
raccontare insieme a raccontare quello
che non stiamo raggiungendo gli
obiettivi che non stiamo raggiungendo le
sfide che dobbiamo affrontare che non
sappiamo come affrontare Allora fosse Sì
sarebbe il momento in cui forse puoi
iniziare un processo di miglioramento
d'inverno miglioramento e
dobbiamo finire di pensare di essere
perfetti non siamo perfetti ma non sono
neanche gli altri e quindi se fossimo un
po' più
trasparenti rispetto alle nostre
attività probabilmente non dovremmo
neanche più di tanto giustificarci
sono tante le aziende che oggi si stanno
scontrando con questo tipo di questo
tipo di concetto è stanno affrontando il
tema della trasparenza
Io ormai lo sfondo come dicevo da una
decina d'anni e ho capito una cosa
la trasparenza è una sorta di una sorta
di arte è roba seria è roba da eroi
perché se da un lato abbiamo la fiducia
che per essere se vogliamo concessa
considera dall'altra parte abbiamo la
trasparenza che invece desidera
considera tutto quello che c'è Non gli
basta desidera sempre qualcosa di
migliore e alla fine non è proprio
questo Cioè non bisogna essere dei veri
e propri Eroi per puntare a raggiungere
i propri desideri
Grazie
[Applauso]